It's great to be back from vacation and I
will talk about what I did on the bonus show,
but we have to jump right into it.
We learned at the start of this weekend that
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
passed away at the age of 87.
And this is simultaneously set off a nationwide.
Really a global mourning period for one of
the premier progressive jurists.
A truly remarkable legal mind whose legal
acumen was surpassed maybe only by her wit
and sense of humor.
And it has set off a political firestorm,
immediately refreshing the battle from the
last year of Barack Obama's presidency over
the nomination of Merrick Garland, then to
replace the late Supreme Court Justice Antonin
Scalia.
That was a nomination, remember, which Republicans
led by Mitch McConnell successfully blocked.
And we're going to be talking about all of
it.
Now, first of all, is the personal.
I'm going to focus on the political.
But Ruth Bader Ginsburg's personal story is
an incredible one.
Born in Brooklyn, at a time when the legal
world was a big uphill battle not just for
women, but for Jewish women.
A tiny woman barely five feet tall, ultimately
becoming the second woman ever to be on the
Supreme Court after Sandra Day O'Connor's
retirement in 2006.
Our Biji was the only woman on the Supreme
Court, a cultural icon well into her 80s,
really a rock star in the political, in the
social and the cultural world.
There is no way to say all of the things that
could be said about Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Now, there is a criticism that she should
have retired when she was, say, 82 years old
already with some health problems to ensure
that Barack Obama would have gotten a clean
chance to choose her replacement to preempt
the situation we now see.
And that is a fair criticism.
And it's in the past and there's nothing we
can do about it now.
And so what is the story now?
Well, the story now is there are 45 ish days
remaining, maybe 45 exactly until an election
in which Donald Trump might lose.
And Donald Trump and Republicans, most Republicans
have shown that they are committed to filling
this seat and filling it as soon as possible.
We're going to talk about who might opt out
of that.
But it is, of course, a huge double standard
in 2016 when Barack Obama was in his last
year.
Republicans said let the people have a say,
let the people vote before we fill the seat.
And indeed, they won on that.
They held the seat.
They refused to give Barack Obama's nominee,
Merrick Garland, confirmation hearings.
And ultimately, Donald Trump filled that seat
a year later with Neil Gorsuch to replace
Antonin Scalia.
And now seemingly the same situation.
Republicans are saying we have a constitutional
duty to fill the seat without delay and they
are going to try.
Now, Mitch McConnell's explanation is, well,
it's not really the same situation because
back in 2016, it was opposite parties in the
Senate and White House.
It was Barack Obama, a Democrat and Republicans
controlling the Senate.
It's different now because it's Republicans
controlling the Senate with a Republican president.
That is their argument.
It's a ridiculous argument.
It is a double standard, but it doesn't matter.
What matters is, are they going to be able
to do it?
And we're going to talk about that in a moment.
The legacy of Ruth Bader Ginsburg is one that
will be studied hopefully for a very long
time.
It's an inspirational story, not just to young
women about someone who really pushed the
boundaries of what society considered to be
the appropriate or valid roles of women in
society.
Really an extraordinary woman, an extraordinary
career.
And again, a cultural and legal icon well
into her 80s.
We will miss her, her legacy.
And now the question is, what will become
of that seat?
And that's what we're going to talk about
next.
We'll talk about process.
And we'll talk about political implications.